pelle a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video io sono fan di j
oggi siamo succhietto mario 3 che è
bello siamo tornati succhiati mario il
secondo episodio raga in teoria in
teoria io dovrei iniziali tutto quanto
perché supermario non si salva ma sapete
che cosa dica che di mario che non lo
farò mai allora che cosa ho avuto cosa
mimuti mente posso premere questo
tastino magico che tu faccia altare di
stage sarebbe lo zero va beh
ero arrivato sia questo qui solo che è
arrivato in una bandiera di mezzo non ci
voglia di riprenderla quindi andiamo
direttamente al 63 quindi ragazzi amo
allo stage presso la fantastica non vedo
la re inizia allora voglio farmi una
tirata sola jolo fin da desinati finisco
cat mario in una sola vita ma è così
michael j
ecco già sbagliato perché non si sale
come si sa le agli 8 chi è questo
ok facciamo che partiamo da adesso sta
cosa di farlo tutto filato ok
bene allora chi è questo non lo so fammi
salire
fammi salire se non fatta [ __ ]
dove è quello stronzo di merda dov'è
l'ho preso l'ho preso al bastardo e qui
i ragazzi qui possiamo sfogarci conto
vogliamo quindi stai tranquillo e non mi
fare incazzata dobbiamo riuscirci da che
in una vita sola impossibile ma ce la
farò primo ok il primo andato bene e qui
ma se russotto ok ragazzi dovrei essere
lo so [ __ ] devo riuscire a passare di
qua draga impossibile vai così non c'era
niente non c'erano trappole impossibile
non ci posso credere
ok adesso allora la bandiera mia la sera
ma la la nuvoletta mi ammazza di sicuro
quindi faccio così non lo sto male te
spararmi anche già che ci siete alla
ragazza situazione veramente brutta non
so come si fa allora fermi oddio oddio
no quando stavo facendo
mi stavo spaventando cioè ero diventato
terminator
non ho ben capito neanche che cosa ho
fatto ok ragazzi sto facendo io ormai
sono posseduto non gioco neanche più il
si muovono la sola e le mani
cosa ho fatto che non ho capito niente
ad aspettare un attimo cipro mai così ma
è così madonna no no sono vivo sono sono
vivo e impossibile da fermi cos'è arriva
ragazzi ci stanno attaccando arrivano
tantissimi e non so cos'è sta roba
tracciato farcia devo fare io devo fare
no madonna non ci credo ragazzi azioni
non ci vogliono
non si voglio crotti madonna che cosa ho
fatto
come puoi morire mini certe situazioni
ora che questa è quella buona lo sento
lo sento e non quella quella dopo quella
dopo quella dopo
ok ragazzi sono di nuovo devo riuscire a
farcela stavolta c'è allora dove sono
morto prima non mi ricordo era tipo qui
c'era una roba ecco perfetto oggi ai
ragazzi già dove fatti no sì o mio dio
no solo mi attacca mi vogliono stuprare
in cinque fermi fermi che mi sta
arrivando di tutto addosso
allora ragazzi ce la sto facendo ma non
so bene allora fermi un attimo
ok di qua si può andare devo prendere
prendo il fanta prendo fantasma prendo
il fantasma no che non ce la faccio
calmi mai così si l'ho preso ok è così
addio addio madonna mia cosa ho fatto
adesso non ci dovrebbero essere più
pericoli non ci dovrebbero essere non lo
so io salto ok bene ho schivato qualcosa
che ho acquistato consistendo a
prescindere quindi divenni andare avanti
la gaiola già paura ad andare avanti
perché so già che muoio io lo so lo so a
prescindere che noi lo stop madonna mia
santi io devo rifarmi tutto da capo ogni
[ __ ] volta è impossibile chiara
caccia forse un po key bene no fermo
fermo o chiara che stavolta ce la faccio
vai così stavolta ce l'ho fatta sembra
essere così
[Musica]
ragazze una scala che di sopra sto
passando è un bug
cos'è ragazzi io non so se un bug c'è la
bandiera madonna mia allora c'è anche
un'altra nuvola che di sicuro mi ammazza
devo assolutamente riuscire ad evitare
quella nuvola perché mi ammazza non so
allora io non ho presente dove ket mario
rispetto allo schermo perché non lo vedo
vado al culo sì che dura non ci credo
che la nova beh ragazzi questo è stata
una botta di culo pazzesca e le rai
adesso è tutto un altro paio di maniche
perché non so che cosa succede perfetto
questa la sapevo questa noi invece non
la sapevo ma sembra sia andare di qua
fatemi capire che cosa ci dovrebbe
essere di diverso maledetti manomesso
muro no no no no no no
[Risate]
mario ragazzi c'è vogliamo vogliamo
scherzare non stiamo scherzando qui c'è
mie mista mi stanno prendendo no no
vuole prendermi in giro
roma stiamo no no mai mai mai mai mai lo
rifarò il dottor a kafka predizione non
ci vuole certo che ore sono
no io devo fare il testamento perché qua
muoio non ci posso credere
[Musica]
ecco questa è una bella idea che non ci
avevo pensato bene allora tutto da capo
cazzo va bene ragazzi per sbaglio che ho
premuto il tasto quello per saltare gli
stage una volta di più quindi sono
arrivato allo stage iv e v se però la
migliore soluzione fra chi era il treno
melari faccio neanche se mi puntano una
pistola alla tempia allora ragazza la
più difficile del solito preso un allora
cia posso fare non ce la posso fare io
penso di potercela fare ma non ce la
faccio
allora ragazzi a pian piano si può
concludere qualcosa credo
ok tipo questo non si può convivere una
beata minchia
ok ragazzo volta è quella buona me lo
sento sì sì ok fermi fermi fermi a chi
doveva essere il bastardo ritorno lì a
destra se non andava bene
maledetti sì sì sì grande così
no grande devo premere l'interruttore
per fare qualcosa non so che cosa serve
ma lo bevo premere quindi ragazzo kay
mai adesso
ok ok perfetto ho premuto bene cosa è
servito ad aumentare la velocità di quei
casi benissimo grande era che queste
sulle soluzioni migliori
ora devo fare una roba tipo alla james
bond ma non so se ci riuscirò ma ci
provo
[Musica]
c'ero quasi riuscito quasi riuscito ma
ovviamente sono morto perché devo morire
se no non c'è gusto ce la posso fare la
gara ce l'ha mi sento carico mi sento
canti tutto in una botta tutto in una
botta tutto in una botta tutto in una
botta pro se chiuso il gioco non è
divertente no l'azzurra che ho capito
che mi sa che avevo ragione prima cioè
dopo prenderlo l'interruttore perché ci
sono le punte di sotto quindi devo
toglierle devo fare così per forza si
infatti è aumenta la velocità dischi
affari però devo devo farlo perché se
non ci sono le punte bene allora tutto
calcolato tutto calcolato
ce la posso fare dai mamma mia non ci
credo vai così la bandiera la bandiera
la bandiera maniera maniera
[Musica]
ragazze non ci posso credere è stata una
cosa epocale quando riuscito a fare le
cose epiche tipo quella di prima fate
come me non esultate per niente come ho
fatto io sono rimasto calmo tranquillo
perché i veri signori fanno così quindi
siate signori come me ce la posso fare
grandissimo ok allora adesso ti conosco
piuttosto non so by giu bene dovevo
riuscire a fare sta allora chissà cosa
nella storia come faccio laga non c'è
niente come ci arrivo dall altra parte
amo quando faccio le domande e la
risposta mi si presenta davanti bene
però non d'acqua come ci arriva uguale
ma che cambia caricando la situazione
mia santis non è possibile cioè io sono
un idiota ce la posso fare ragazzi cani
devo riuscire a colpire tipo qualcosa se
non sapevo nel profondo del mio cuore
ragazzi lo sapevo ce la posso fare
adesso sì adesso adesso un cazzo
praticamente però ce la posso provarci
posso riprovare è devono riuscire ad
arrivarci adesso fai anche alla tua
parte maledetto se il bravo allora che
oggi stiamo dobbiamo arrivare un'altra
bandiera perché se no continuiamo così
per secoli tipo adesso
non amiamo donna mi devo ricordare ogni
volta che salto da qualche parte di
saltare prima per vedere se ci sono dei
cubi maledetti perché ci sono ovunque mi
mettono anche nel didietro
ok ce la posso fare calmi ce l'ho già
fatto una volta resta parte una cazzata
adesso non mi prendete per il culo
perché so che state ridendo sotto i
baffi perché io sono stupido però è
anche colpa sua ci si mette anche lui
quando non deve quindi essi però magari
giorgio che resti giochi formale fa
proprio male al cervello allo stress
una persona è stressata devi andare devi
saltare se premo il tasto suo l'hanno
fatto apposta è un riuscirà non salta
cioè devo arrivare tipo non lo so perché
ci saranno due miliardi di trappole io
già lo so se faccio così
lo sai io lo sapevo lo sapevo anche l'ho
detto l'ho detto prima di saltare che
c'era nelle trappole perché ci sono
andato lo stesso non ci casco più salto
direttamente su cosa nostro cioè su cosa
marrone bene bene bene se grande oggi
posso credere
[Musica]
adesso vi sorprenderete delle doti
incredibili perché finisco che mario lo
finisco nel senso che lo uccido cioè era
questo il senso la mia parte lo finisco
nel senso che adesso uccido che mario
cioè boom sei finito
sono un fallito ha richiesto che ti
vantaggio gara stampa
vabbè io ci provo lo stesso adesso
sentite ragazzi io la chiudo qui perché
il mio cervello mi sta lentamente
abbandonando anche se penso che ci abbia
lasciato un po di tempo fa ma vabbè io
la chiudo qui perché non ci sto più
facendo senti concludi tu perché non ho
la forza di farlo ma non sai parlare a
non sai non sai né parlare né saltare ma
che cazzo osservi fammi capire
chiudo io lasciamo perdere le smancerie
finali perché devo andare a farmi una
doccia fredda per calmarmi quindi lega
se vi è piaciuto lasciate un commento mi
piace anche la pagina di facebook e come
in ogni video trovate nella descrizione
svendsen da quelli scritti iscrivetevi
noi ci rivediamo in un prossimo video
bene ragazzi